Speaker 1: Let's chat with people
from the audience. So important.
I want to hear from you. Without you, I'm a guy
in a room and it's sad and nobody listens. So we
do these calls via discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. We're going to start today.
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly with is it
Tanya from Texas? Is that the way it's pronounced?
Tanya from Texas, welcome. You have to unmute
yourself. I've unmuted you, but I can see you
have muted yourself. Tanya, welcome.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much.
Okay. Since the 2020 election, I have had a
suspicion that the fact that Biden won the
White House and Republicans won the Senate had
something to do with a whole bunch of new voters
coming out and not voting down ballot.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second. Hold
on a second, Tanya. Democrats won the Senate.
What do you mean, Republicans won the Senate?
Speaker 2: I mean. I mean,
I'm. I'm nervous. I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: You're doing great.
Speaker 2: With
with what everyone was hearing, referring
to as a mandate to work together because.
Speaker 1: Wait. So let's take a step back,
Tonya, so I can figure it out. So, yes, in 2020,
Joe Biden won the White House and took it from
Trump. Democrats secured the Senate with a 5050
Senate. But Kamala Harris is the tie breaking vote
and Democrats controlled the House. Are we on the
same page as far as that goes?
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 1: Okay. So your question was.
Speaker 2:
There was there was talk about this mandate
for for Biden to work together with the other
side because of. Oh.
Speaker 1: Tanya.
Speaker 2: Oh, my gosh. I'm curious. Okay. I'm
going to reduce it to this, please. Your thoughts
on the fact that people need to vote all the way
down the ballot? I never hear anyone talking about
it. It seems like it would have consequences.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I mean, we must all vote.
We must all vote all the way down the ballot.
If you show up and you check a box for senator
in November and then you don't do congressperson.
You don't do gubernatorial. You don't do attorney
general, secretary of state, state, senate.
All of the I mean, listen, you get you're going
there once and voting. You might as well make
your voice heard on every single one of them
and people not doing that. Tonya helps Republicans
sneak in these extremists into local office. So
you better be do your homework and be ready to
fill out your ballot fully and completely, please.
Speaker 2: Yes, I agree. And I wonder why that's
not a major topic of discussion. I appreciate your
patience with me. Thank you so much, Tanya.
Speaker 1: It's been a pleasure. Things
are okay in Texas.
Speaker 2: I'm hanging
on in there, and I'm hoping for Mateo.
Speaker 1: Okay. We're all hoping. All
right. Thank you, Tanya, very much. Appreciate
it. An important issue which we landed on there.